she's an American soccer player an
Olympic gold medalist
she's a forward for the Portland thorns
FC and for the u.s. women's national
soccer team she was a US soccer female
athlete of the year and a FIFA World
Player of the Year finalist
she's Alex Morgan and here her top ten
rules for success I played a lot of
sports when I was younger and I settled
on soccer because the 99 team really
motivated me my dad would go out on the
soccer field with me every day and it
pushed myself in a good way and
motivated me to be the best I could be
soccer was just my thing and I wanted to
make it to the US Women's National Team
my favorite goal was getting steadily I
scored in probably the 93rd minute and I
think that's one of the best parts of my
game is my finishing
everyone has their talent but it's what
you do with that talent to make it great
I'm not worried about my future about
what I'm going to do in ten years after
soccer it's about right now you know how
I can contribute to the team's success
how I can make sure that you know I'm
physically mentally ready for each game
so it's it's really just taking it day
by day and knowing that you know the
feature is so uncertain you just need to
be happy where you are right now and
just have a positive outlook on so in
the morning I get a good night's sleep
and then in the mornings I try and get
out here on Alki just kind of walk
around it's just a really beautiful
place to kind of start your morning and
have a positive mentality going into
your day
Yoga definitely fits into my life in
terms of preparation it's great just to
have that sense of feeling at ease with
yourself stretching is a huge part of
soccer and making sure that you know
you're pretty flexible and I just love
the feeling of kind of being alone a
little bit and being able to take my
mind off the soccer but at the same time
the reason I go to yoga is to help me
succeed in soccer I didn't expect when I
sprained my ankle back in October late
October that it would come to this and
that was the hardest part for me it was
kind of doubting myself like well you
know why didn't I
why didn't I take it easier why didn't I
kind of pull myself out of training or
out of the game but you can't look back
you kind of just need to look forward it
was it was definitely hard but I feel
like now that I'm actually seeing
improvement we just got a muraayn it
kind of helps me a little bit mentally
to be able to do bike a little bit to be
able to swim I wasn't able to do
anything on crutches so now knowing that
there's improvement I'm able to do some
stuff I feel a lot more I guess happy
before every game the key to my
preparation is consistency I really
think that every athlete is a little bit
superstitious and if an athlete tells
you otherwise I think they're lying so
yes I do a couple of things I definitely
put on my red sock before my left sock
and I like to take a nap at the same
time and eat the same things and then
right before the game I like to do
of mental visualization so I'll go in a
locker and just put on headphones and
just imagine myself in the game when
people ask me how I balance non soccer
stuff that things off the field I you
know I think it just I've been more
confident in the last couple of years
with the decisions I make and
opportunities that are given and
decisions whether to go through with it
or not you know if it's authentic to Who
I am and you know whether it's a company
I'm representing or whether it's an
event I'm going to whether it's a photo
shoot that I've been asked to to do I
think it's you know it's just weighing
all of the things and making sure that
nothing is standing in the way of what I
do best and what I'm here for and that's
to play soccer I think there's no secret
to success I mean I think a B definitely
hit the nail on the head it's it's all
about hard work it's all about going out
there and and practicing more than your
opponent than your teammates it's it's
about mentally preparing every single
day it's about not slacking off putting
in that time and work and you could tell
from Abby that she is put in that work
and that's I think the reason that she
is hooks is so successful but at the end
of the day end of the day there is no
there is no secret to why we are so
successful I think most forwards like to
play under pressure or else you wouldn't
play the forward position but I do like
that pressure and sometimes you don't
always succeed and that's okay and as a
forward you have to find that balance I
mean you're going to shoot five times
and maybe you'll score once maybe you
won't you know maybe you'll get three
goals out of three shots so it's a
little unpredictable and you just kind
of got to go with it and have confidence
in yourself you know I wanted to be an
Olympic gold medalist since
but since I was seven years old so but
that was a dream cultural models are who
my role models I mean I definitely
looked up to Kristine Lilly Mia Hamm
Abbi even in high school and getting on
the national team but I feel like I
always wanted to kind of make my parents
proud and they were like the two people
that came to every single game and just
were my biggest fans so you know it's
not what I wanted them to see I just
wanted them to feel the passion and I
wanted them to to grow that passion
because this is exactly what I dreamed
of when I was a young kid when I was
watching you this is what I dreamed of -
I'm gonna cry you're gonna make me cry
stop just a dream big
cuz dreams do happen thank you guys so
much for watching I made this video
because Efrain Pinto asked me to for his
daughter so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Alex
Morgan's top ten rules you like the best
leave it in the comments I'm going to
join in the discussion thank you guys so
much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon